what I hear you asking is what about the
dark side of psychedelics and I think
that's certainly worth talking about
it isn't a joyride necessarily one thing
that is quite wonderful about
psychedelics is that and I'll just speak
of the mushroom in this case is that
it's wonderfully kind to beginners but
if you are an acolyte of the priesthood
sooner or later it will scare the socks
off you and in many ways it can do this
in fact that's what's so scary about it
is it knows the way to scare you just
like it knows everything else about you
and so so in my talk I stress the
facility with which one can access these
places and I sort of teased yoga it is
easy to access these places the question
is then but is it easy to control and
manipulate and understand these places
and this is where it can turn you every
way but loose this is where you want to
have your mantras polished and your
Yantra is ready because in that domain
it all works
all that malarkey that doesn't ever work
anywhere else in that domain it works
and and so I think one should have
techniques you know the ring past knot
or mantras something that you have faith
in power objects ultimately the best
advice I've ever come on and you know
it's pretty sickening advice but the
goal is to survive these things is Frank
Herbert's advice in Doom about fear and
he says fear comes like a wind it comes
and the way you meet it is you meet it
and you wait and it blows and it blows
and it blows itself out and then you're
alone again and that's what you have to
do and then in terms of practical
instruction there are way ways to
navigate through hard spots birth
control
singing singing is wonderful we tend to
suffer silently and if you get into a
pressurised place on a psychedelic I
don't think it's a good idea to go to
squeeze down and to meet it like that I
think it's much better to sing to you
know circulate huge volumes of oxygen
through your body and just send your
whole metabolism spiraling off in some
other direction shamanism was defined by
the foremost commentator on it mursili
odd as the archaic techniques of ecstasy
notice its techniques and this is really
important
this is not a religion or an ontology or
a set of beliefs like Buddhism Hinduism
Catholicism you name it it's a set of
techniques and the techniques deliver
the experience and then out of the
experience one creates whatever models
of the universe seem appropriate that
this is what science was before science
this is what religion was before
religion and it's deep it's the deepest
thing there is our society living in
ignorance of this is infantile and
destructive and narcissistic and
materialistic and but here damn it
because we can't touch the gold in life
you know it's hard for us it's very
invasive it's far from us authenticity
is fleeting and we require
psychotherapists
some self-affirmation all the stuff to
hang on to it how I got into this like
the gentleman who asked the question is
by being in the Amazon by having
searched India to see so you know what
can you show me and they couldn't show
me anything they wanted me to sweep the
ashram for 12 years and then something
wonderful is going to happen and I am
back then when I got to South America
Sarepta be shining in the sky said let's
sharpen our machetes we'll go out here
and flip some of this snake line and
come back and I'll show you and by 10
o'clock that night you know I was
sobbing in the guy's arms he showed me I
was a convert I'd sweep his courtyard
for 12 years without asking
[Music]
you